herzlich kommen sollte man folglich
fahrer leute heute mit einem
atemberaubenden schätzchen hier neben
mir audi rs 6
[Musik]
dass der wagen von jannik und weil es
geht grüßen c8 wie gar nicht viel reden
kommt mal rum weil der yannick ist heute
mit pizza blech hierhergekommen guckt
euch mal siehst du das wenn sie seht ihr
diese bremsscheiben was ist das denn für
ein absurder scheiß das ist doch
mal ein mal deinen kopf daneben
aber die bühne hier made in germany
richtig geil carbon keramik er sehr sehr
geil die blauen bremssättel steht sogar
drauf richtig richtig killer 22 zoll
felgen 600 ps 3,6 sekunden auf 100 und
800 newtonmeter aus einem 4 liter v8
biturbo geil endlich wieder vier ringe
richtig richtig killer ist die farbe ab
wäre ja das ist irgendwie so geil matte
lackierung ist es diese alu matt was so
oder jagen und jana genau killer hinten
dagegen guck mal das ist immer eine
große scheibe die sich homann aus
muss aber auch sein gutes ding wiegt
auch 2,5 tonnen glaube ich ja genauso da
brauchst du auch so ein pizza blech
kommt man nach hinten leute also liste
kostet der spass basis 117 1500 mai
nicht genau wo sind wir hier so
roundabout das waren knapp 170
170 rex killer wir hinten auf die
blenden drauf leute das sind sind die
schwarzen also has performance der neuen
anlage hat auch geklappt abgasanlage
direkt vorne ist
rechtlich genau diese laufen ich habe
ich erzählt immer schluss in die videos
glaube ich nicht ich dachte klappen an
langen gibt's nicht mehr ja aber an die
warte aber du darfst du hast keinen klub
mehr drin für an aus das ist es nämlich
das ist mit dem dynamic modus in einem
zug machen die an auf ihn nachdem erst
wenn ihr mal reinschaut leute sieht es
auch seht ihr die klappe und
ja ist schon sexy schön die typischen
ovale es ist so breit übrigens leute er
ist 6 weiß man ja ist auf der basis von
a6 aber soviel basis ist eigentlich gar
nicht drin ich habe ja die vorderen
türen das dach und noch eine sache von
a6 sonst ist es komplett quasi eine
eigenentwicklung in dem sinne von der
audi sport gmbh ehemals quattro gmbh der
wird auch in neckarsulm gebaut nicht in
ingolstadt richtig killer komm komm ans
fenster leute kommen was uns hier an
lacht ist das geil jetzt mit dem
sonnenuntergang hier guck mal dieses
alcantara lenkrad
hammermäßig und jetzt hier die für die
neuen high class audis typischen
doppelbildschirm hast du damit stress
bisschen viele fingerabdrücke und er
übrigens leute könnt ihr euch auch dazu
sagen er wollte immer gerne wissen wie
kommen meine gäste an solche autos
karakus dazu erzählen wir sind
autovermieter also schmidt wir sind
nicht einfach unsere privatsphäre nicht
vermieten die deswegen ist das alles
macht macht wenn ihr in bielefeld in der
nähe seid und mal bock habt auch nicht
alles aus sein könnte bei uns euch bei
yannic melden denkmal website ist auf
jeden fall in der beschreibung
boateng 22 zoll weil du weißt du bereits
aus dem kopf auf die gruppen aufpreis
kosten das ist das ganze eher ist
dynamik paket da das nochmal 15 aufpreis
da ist dann aber auch das dynamit paket
mit den displays und der abgasanlage und
was da alles drin ja das sind schon
ansagen von einem von der bremse heißt
das schon sehr sehr stark von der
bremsleistung ist schon was nicht
richtig rein geht dann das ende also da
muss ja muss ja da denke ich jetzt mit
schrecken zurück an den 300 sl genau
freund an den 3ds aber die bremsen die
waren wirklich hardcore ja dass also die
trommelbremsen das gar keinen druck
kommen egal das programm heute hier
nicht noch mal kurz in den motorraum
rennen gerne interessant ist nämlich
auch der rs6 ist ja nicht einfach nur
ein power kommt kombi sondern er hat
auch richtig vorgeschichte wenn ich mich
recht erinnere war es damals der erst
zwei kennt sie kennst du den noch
erkennen von von audio porsche zusammen
entwickelt der so diese klasse power
kombi eigentlich mitbegründet hat und
zumindest in der hinsicht ist hier so
der nachfrage davon und ich muss
eigentlich auch sagen rs6 dass wir doch
ja okay es dafür gerade erachte ich nur
daran geworden ist sehr der rs6 ist ja
eigentlich der power kombi so der hat
die der ist das gesicht der klasse so
beim m5 gibt 60 61 oder danach kein
touring wer das war der letzte touring
e63 t modell gibt es aber noch an die
amg bis ich mag es ja auch aber das
juckt mich auch nicht so sehr wie sex
das ist so der bauer kombi killer ja ich
stehe steht sollte v8 phase sieht man
mal was da an technik drin ist das
klingt ja fast hier aus werden auch wenn
du den an machst da geht geführt mit
ganze ganzes kraftwerken so laut ist ja
geil 1000 lifter verbaut das ist schon
sehr laut dann richtig richtig richtig
sexy aber dem dem v8 ist es schon ein
bisschen engländer ja da muss ich ein
bisschen kuscheln mit der ganzen technik
aus rum wäre das aber megageil kommen
schon mal schnell rein steigt man doch
gerne ein
hier die einstiegsleiste rs6 damit man
nicht vergisst
das ist so ein geiles auto dicker
unfassbar
wenn man s reifen
nein ich glaube dass sommerreifen drauf
ja bei winterreifen kommen noch drauf
weil leute kommen warum digger geil wäre
das hier da muss ich ja kurz mal hier
aber nachfragen dann kann ja ich nicht
sagen wir schauen mal eben adac sagt
hankook ventus s1 evo 3 1 sommerreifen
naja ok du sagst der hat das performance
paket ist er auf 280 dann auf 305 305 3
ps 6 ist serie auf 250 gehen wir von
vier autos kennt und dann geht der spaß
los mit den ganzen aufpreispflichtigen
paketen der erste geht bis 280 dann und
zweiten volle möhre rente dann 305 genau
und wahrscheinlich auch ohne größere
probleme nein gar nicht das ding ist hat
die hohen geschwindigkeiten sind auch in
dem fall sind noch ein bisschen unbequem
wenn er gleich wieder nach dem anschauen
wird die ganze noch mit und das ist
alles noch ein bisschen
wankelmütig mal ist es war also nicht
mehr allzu komfortabel okay was kann man
noch sei er ist 6 hatten starter
generator 48 volt bordnetz also mit
hybrid also nicht plugin sondern der
rekuperiert dann auch in der arbeit des
todes schwache batterie als der glaube
ich 0 5 kilowattstunden ich weiß nicht
genau hat hat meine coupé auch als es
von miramax macht es einfach ein
bisschen sparsamer
interessanteste bei meinem höre ich das
ganz krass wenn ich langsam anfange
so geht mit dem elektromotor wird was
aber jetzt wahrscheinlich zu viel mehr
habe ich nicht gehört guy leute
ihr wisst was auf keinen fall fehlen
darf leute soundcheck jannik wenn du
einmal rein springst selbstverständlich
und ich spaziere einfach mal nach hinten
mit einem lockeren schritten
kommt vom band kommt rein manchmal
hab jetzt gehen wir mal
das ist richtig tief das ist richtig
geil aber man muss halt auch sagen ganz
ganz krasser unterschied im vergleich
zum sls zum beispiel das sind einfach
die auflagen jetzt also beim sls dinge
die ohren weg das ist ganz entspannt und
er knallt auch nicht und so also
zumindest nicht wenn man jetzt im
leerlauf gas gibt geil ja dann würde ich
sagen machen wir noch einen
kofferraumdeckel und
beim kofferraum check leute können wir
an dieser stelle auch ein schauder für
den sponsor vom heutigen video geben
denn das ist dream ii in diesem koffer
raum in dem man wie man sehen auch ganz
gut man menschen transportieren kann
habe ich für euch den dream i t30 dabei
hier schon mit dem passenden auf das für
die auto- reinigung der trinität 30
seinen akku staubsauger jetzt hier schon
mit dem passenden aufsatz für die
richtigen ecken im auto ich hab ich mal
ein paar von den aufsätzen auch
mitgenommen die man dabei mit kommen
unter anderem sind ganz ganz ganz viele
wir bekommen auf seine band take that
die hier und diese gibt sich mal dieses
sauguat ackerbohnen bruder sergej der
sex dreht wenn mich nicht alles täuscht
und immer kurz darauf geschaut so bis
knapp vor 7000 der hier macht 150000
umdrehung mit der turbine hat eine
laufzeit von bis zu 90 minuten und ich
zeige ich das ganze einmal tut mir für
mich
einen dreck hier ein weil der rhein waal
landwirte demonstrieren und zwar hier
der trinität 30 verschiedene modi bis
jetzt gerade im eco modus gibt noch
mittel turbo und dann im auto modus und
wenn wir jetzt einmal hier gas geben
seht ihr der hat hier so eine anzeige
das level die restliche akkulaufzeit hat
jetzt nicht ganz voll laden können dass
level also wie viel dreck man quasi hat
und im auto-modus passt er sich von
selbst an an die menge von dreck die man
so ist hier aber keinen dreck jetzt
gehen auch den dreck zu
der hier
wenn wir den dreck sind hier rein weil
dann erhält er automatisch das gas und
jetzt hektisch so jan gespräche gesagt
hat allerdings wissen weil keller und
beste mit dem aufsatz kann jetzt ja auch
dazwischen
und auch hier innen drin den dreck
rausholen perfekt der ganze baum sammelt
sich dann hier drin kommt mit kann man
dann wieder erde zu erde hier einfach
einmal den knopf drücken war und die
kiste wieder sauber ich hab von grimmig
oder weise sogar noch ein anderes gerät
für zuhause bekommen hat damit jetzt
schon mehrmals meine bude durch gesagt
und es ist wirklich schoko ich war bis
dato immer noch mit so einem staubsauger
mit kabel unter weg macht gar keinen
sinn leute also das mit akku wer jetzt
sich im schloss wohnt und 800
quadratmeter sorgen macht das schon sind
kann ich empfehlen eine killer
information habe ich noch für euch und
zwar aber ich kann mir ja ein bisschen
auf kamera geschnappt hat man gar nicht
geredet sagt man wie dazu
hätte das gedacht schon mal die
kommentare rein wie alt hätte dir ja
nicht geschätzt hand aufs herz tages ein
bisschen dumm macht eigentlich anders
rum aber wir sind nicht dumm ist halt so
leute und das mich auch interessieren
würde was wäre ihre wahl für den power
kombi würdet ihr auf 16 gehen oder e63
t-modell oder habt ihr noch was anderes
im kopf kann ja auch mal rein schreiben
und wir schreiben jetzt nicht mehr wir
steigen ein und fahren runde jetzt kommt
oder sind wir heute erst sechs wir
sitzen drin wenn einmal nach unten
werden das hier ist finde ich so sex ich
hab mir auch mal für mich und max mal
angeschaut a7 das finde ich sogar die
klimasteuer hinten einfach pommes und
jetzt wundert sich vielleicht jetzt auf
dem fahrersitz liegt daran die sondern
läuft uns davon deswegen
fahre ich einfach direkt am anfang
vielleicht macht es natürlich wenn man
immer so dann würde das heute passt auf
jeden fall bin ich heiß und wir starten
jetzt
geil auch komme es sogar der der visa
der fahrmodus will schalter sowie sohn
jett er ist auch mit alcantara bezogen
alcantara lenkrad sehr sexy
ist man direkt
ultramodernes auto 22 tonnen fossile
spazieren fährt und es ist alles
entspannt ganz ganz locker ganz lässiges
gaspedal auch jetzt hier im komfort
modus über sind ne ganz relaxed aber man
spürt schon da ist ein v8
einmal kannst du dir laut machen genau
das so jetzt ist ja auch in schwung
vor
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja
herrscht wirklich ordentlich an der
kollege ist zwar ganz schnell aus der
stadt heraus das lenkrad ist auch geil
die schaltwippen sind sehr zivilisiert
ne
sehen müssen weil der partie hatte auch
solche teller
das ist ja entspannt
du hast jetzt ganz komisch auch
alcantara mit lenkradheizung habe ich
noch nie ok ich
finde dass
das so krass dass der wagen power hat
der strahlt das richtig aus aber
trotzdem auch sehr zivilisiert
natürliche partner auf der straße
das ding ist das habe ich kann auch hart
sein wenn du möchtest na ja deswegen ist
jetzt würde ich sehr oft strecke auch
ausgelegt also können stecken aber es
kann sehr sehr stark dämpfen ja
das mahlwerk grüße gehen raus an die
rennleitung wie drüben
alles gut
den job für leute wir warten auf das
heilige zeichen mit den drei grauen
strichen
in schutz
der zug
der schiebt einfach wie sagt man das ist
so lala
ist das ein schwor die chance hätte sind
so schnell
euro
und die bremsen packen zu bohren die
power das ist man die bremse
das wasser das wasser schmeißen richtig
fette party 116 grad
dieser spruch
weil meine leute man merkt dass der
schub klasse ist wenn man vom gas geht
und dann nochmal zum zweiten schlag
bekommt davon dass der schub offheimer
weg ist und
ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja
ist es doch der richter
zenit gewann beat ist dass kranke eltern
war
aber eigentlich müsste noch einmal
launch control machen so leute machen
jetzt noch mal haben die lautsprecher
nicht ganz raus bekommen wir sind ready
und ja
jetzt kommt der schuhtick
armer leute und damit vielen dank gerne
wenn die bewertung als gott und
bewertung beginnt eben wieder aus der
sex ist auf jeden fall ein sehr frisches
auto meiner meinung nach fehlt mir aber
noch so ein detail was denn so wirklich
wirklich außergewöhnlich schön macht und
auf die neun von zehn oder gar zehn von
zehn eben würde deswegen gebe ich ab
konzert die beschleunigung fühlt sich
richtig richtig brachial an also wird in
jeder lage richtig potent und stark der
motor gerade und rom mit dem heiraten
nach vorne aber der erste hat bist du
dann in seinem speck mit seinen 2,2
tonnen und auch 36 sekunden das reicht
für 820 bei der cool ist aber ist der
sex ganz vorn er ist einfach die power
kombi ikone quasi der nachfahre vom
legendären erst zwei und ich war
überrascht wie viele leute in köln sich
umgedreht haben nach uns gerufen haben
das hat man mit dem amg in der form
irgendwie nicht so und deswegen gibt's
19 war das wetter kommt damit auch für
einen kombi legendäre 25 von 30 punkten
was von anfang natürlich klarer ist die
praktikabilität über jeden zweifel
erhaben ist klar der verbrauch ist
relativ hoch der tank ist nicht
gigantisch mit 170 litern aber da geht
einfach alles reiniger da kannst du
deine mutter und meine oma und noch
gefühl noch golf noch rein laden in
diesem kofferraum da ist einfach endlos
viel platz man kann super entspannen mit
vier leuten reisen vielleicht sogar mit
5 9 von 10 preis leistung wie immer
schwierig leute man hat mit dem erst
sechs mal wieder eine eierlegende
wollmilchsau sowie der asco acht auch
eine war und vor allem der gt 63 erst
von remy eine war er ist aber das finde
ich sehr gut nochmal eine ganze ecke
günstiger als er geht hier 63 ist also
günstiger anführungszeichen immer noch
170.000 euro das heißt insgesamt aber
meiner meinung nach für einen punkt mehr
als er gegen 60 erst- und damit sieben
von zehn zum schluss der komfort der rs6
natürlich erwartungsgemäß richtig gut
wie es beim fahrzeuge dieser klasse auch
sein sollte einzig die 22 zoll felgen
oder die tatsache dass er jetzt keinen
luftfahrwerk hat ein bisschen die punkte
und verhindern dass er neun von zehn
bekommt deswegen gibt es acht von zehn
alltags wertungen 24 von 30 und
insgesamt leute haltet euch fest 49 von
60 punkten und damit platz eins der
schreiber in die kommentare was davon
haltet und ob wir vielleicht anders
bewerten würde und wir sehen uns nicht
ein sonntag wieder los geht raus und
euch heute bis dann